in this lesson we're going to talk about
piecewise functions so on the act at
least in the past acts when they've
presented problems like this it's
usually a multiple choice you know
problem well that's of course it's
multiple choice but what they'll do is
they'll give you a bunch of different
graphs right and you just have to select
you know which one is the appropriate
graph well what you can do on a problem
like that is of course you can pick some
test values and see which ones are going
to you know correspond to the graphs and
which ones don't but i just want to have
you do some practice on this particular
question so you can be familiar with how
these piecewise functions work to help
narrow down your choices a little bit
quicker so go ahead and pause the video
see if you can graph this function and
we'll do it together
so g of x when you see g of x or f of x
or h of x you can think of that as y so
what we have here is we have y equals x
plus 2
only when x is less than negative 2. so
less than means to the left right so
what you could do is you could graph
okay y equals x plus 2 it has a y
intercept of 2 and it has a slope of
positive one which means you're going up
one over one like this so it's a line
like this
but it's when x is less than two so an
easier way to do this is to make a
little table
and just pick values that are negative
two and smaller right we know it's going
to be a straight line because it's in
the form y equals mx plus b let's just
pick some values so negative 2 times 1
is negative 2 plus 2 is 0. negative 3
plus 2 is
negative 1 negative 4 is negative 2
negative 3. so if we plot these points
we get negative 2 0 now the important
thing here is that when x is less than
negative 2 right not including negative
2 so that means we're going to have this
as an open circle it's not going to be
closed it would only be filled in or
closed if it was equal to and then we've
got negative 3
negative 1 and negative four negative
two and you can see it's a line that's
going off in that direction to the left
so less than or to the left of negative
two
now the next one it's y equals four and
we know line the line y equals four is a
horizontal line okay right here at four
in between negative 2 and 2 including
negative 2 and 2. see the equal signs so
i'm going to go up to here i'm going to
make this a filled in circle i'm going
to go up to positive 2 that's a filled
in circle and we've got our horizontal
line the last one you can see it's an x
squared which means we know it's a
parabola the negative x squared means
it's opening down like this
and the plus 3 means we're shifting the
graph up 3. but again i'm going to use
this table method i think this is an
easy way to do it and just pick values
that are greater than 2. now i'm putting
2 here because we're interested in to
the points up to 2 but not including 2
so i'm just going to use 2 3 and 4. so 2
squared is 4 times negative 1 is
negative 4 plus 3 is negative 1. 3
squared is 9 times negative 1 is
negative 9 plus 3 is negative 6 and 4
squared is 16 times negative 1 is
negative 16 plus 3 is negative 13 right
so if we plot these
2 negative 1 this is going to be open
because again it's greater than 2 but
not equal to 2.
3 is going to be negative 6 so that's
going to be let's see 2 3 4 5 6 right
about there and then 4 is going to be
way down here at negative 13. so we can
see this graph is
it looks like a straight line but it
actually has a little bit of a curve to
it if you were to graph the entire
parabola it looks something like this
this is a little bit of a curve to it
and that's your piecewise function so
again you can pick points like i did
here to narrow down your choices when
you're doing that multiple choice
piecewise graph a question
i'll see you in the next lesson